take the responsibility and take
responsibility take responsibility
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
under the world now I started the one
rule series because we do a lot of top
tens a lot of the messages come up over
and over and over and over again and
some of the most consistently repeated
messages by all of these successful
people we smush into the one rule series
and so today we're going to learn how
you can take responsibility enjoy one of
the things that's really interesting
about the Old Testament is that and the
Jews in the Old Testament is that they
don't take the path of Cain every time
they're walloped by God which is like
fairly frequently they say we must have
done something wrong and we have to set
our self right and that's an
unbelievably heroic attitude because
that's the alternative to cursing fate
it's like you take the responsibility
for failure onto yourself and you think
well if I was just maybe if I just had
my act together a little bit more if I
took advantage of every opportunity that
was put in front of me if I wasn't
resentful and bitter then I could have
done something that would have tilted
the situation in a different direction
and like that's almost inevitably true
Dostoevsky I think said something like
every man is responsible for everything
that happens to him and everything that
happens to everyone else and that's you
know that that's that's it's a crazy
statement right it's a crazy statement
and he was a pretty extreme person in
many many ways but there's a level at
which that's metaphysically true you
know because what happens is that it's
you its failure to act often that's the
most catastrophic you know I mean I've
it's it's it's to not do the right thing
when the when the situation presents
itself and it's very specific you know
you're constantly in situations where
you could do the right
if you were willing to take a risk
that's actually of relatively moderate
size and you know that you could take
the risk and you know that you should
take the risk and you don't and that
happens to people all the time and then
what happens is the thing that they
didn't oppose grows a little bit and
they shrink a little bit and that starts
a loop hey what did you find fascinating
about Tyler the Creator from our future
I found that he was he was a young kid
but he was extremely disciplined and
however he put his self together and he
would do various things you know what
you'll notice on on 15 of these subjects
is they all do various different things
but it's the same exact thing and you'll
notice that we we no longer are take
control of our lives many of us we allow
the rest of the world to take care take
take our responsibilities from us and
make us their problem right so we have
to be selfish and I looked at it in a
certain way that Tyler was being selfish
in the same way
I'll give you example I'll get right
back to how Tyler is when we wake up in
the morning we usually have a hundred
emails and then we then go and look on
social media and we then kiss the kids
or the husband of the wife whatever and
run out we go on you know we get in the
car and we listen to the news an entire
world blew up and then we get to the
office we're dealing with everybody else
we get home cook for the kids or maybe
the husband wife or the roommate and
then we started all over again well what
I noticed with the people earlier on in
their in their lives or in their day
what they do the first 90 minutes is
they get up they don't answer any emails
for the first hour because they don't
care about everybody else's problems
they send out emails but they won't
answer everybody else's because we're so
busy taking care of everybody else's
problems they won't look at social media
because you get social media depression
because everybody on social media is
doing great they got a big car they're
all beautiful they all got big butts or
skinny butts whatever you like right and
you
you're late for work right you don't
even put any time in so what these
people do is they won't answer any mean
email because they look at their inbox
as their defense they look at the outbox
opens they'll send out all these emails
they won't look at social media they'll
go ahead and take time and schedule time
with their kids that wipe over it is for
the next night or tomorrow or whatever
the case is because they know they keep
saying we'll hang out they'll never get
to it they eat something healthy they'll
do four sets of twenty five like you
said you'll do four sets of twenty five
push-ups get the adrenaline running then
they'll get out there and they'll start
doing things and what people would
usually don't do is they never take time
for themselves to ask themselves who do
they want to be tomorrow next year in
ten years and Tyler even as a young kid
he'll go out there and he'll sit in a
tree for an hour with his friends yeah
here just send the tree because we
usually forget who we wanted to be we're
answering everybody else around where a
mother or a father were a husband where
or whoever else and he takes up about an
hour a day and sits a tree and writes
everything down he doesn't put it on his
cell phone he doesn't put it in his
smartphone on the tablet and he used
that as a Bible and every day keeps
navigating him towards success and I've
noticed that every person in the book
does the same exact thing in one form or
another they may do it at midnight they
may do it in the morning time but they
all give praise they think what they
have around them and then they see how
they can build on it by thinking about
who they want to be instead of letting
everybody else in the world tell them
what they want from them just enough
enough enough like living by somebody
else's rules is a humongous mistake I
just literally sat down with five people
under the age of twenty seven and it's
so refreshing it is so refreshing if you
have not jumped on the bandwagon of
doing exactly what the you want to do
which is skiing for the next three years
or working at a job that's not what your
parents want or what society wants this
video is just called enough enough make
this little one two minute video depends
on when I finish the piece of content
that gets you to stand up and take life
by its throat do something stopping
scared stop letting the way you were
raised the
or as an offense take that away let me
be the person I'll take the blame I
loved that some of my plays are like my
parents don't love what you're saying
good parents because if you are playing
defense and if you are living a life
where your kids lives are the way you're
being fulfilled you're a loser
parents and so enough enough parents
imposing their way you want your kids to
be happy on your terms enough the kid
that's sitting right now in a desk and
saw this in a feed and you hate your job
enough stand up get the [ __ ] out of here
and do you live your life you've got one
life do something about it second one is
that you've been lied to for a really
long time that school is a scam that
teaches people to be compliant that
tells you to only listen to things that
are on the test encourages you to do the
minimum amount because whatever you get
away was the rest of the times yours
that's what we teach you in school we
invented that so that you would get a
factory job and do what you were told
because factories needed it so that's
why they invented school and the
brilliant insight that changes
everything for people is realizing that
responsibility is never given it's taken
and then if you choose to take
responsibility all these doors open up
and that you get a totally different
life in exchange because striving for
authority hoping someone will give you a
license to tell other people what to do
that's pretty rare but if you're willing
to take responsibility then no one can
get in your way I don't think if people
take enough responsibility for where
they are in life I think it's too easy
to blame other people it's too easy to
blame your government or blame your
family for not having the right
connections or blame your bank for not
giving you the money or you know blame
your circumstances it's too easy the
thing that you need to do the taking
responsibility is painful it's painful
it's way easier to say well I'm not
successful because of this person or
this person or this person it's not
because of you no of course not it's
because of your president that's why
you're not successful and it's not until
you actually look yourself in a mirror
and realize that there is no cavalry
coming to save the day for you you know
there's no fairy godmother coming down
to grant your every wish it's on you and
you are responsible for where you are
right now you you may not be responsible
for you know where you're born but once
you become an adult you know you're a
salsa for your life you can only blame
your parents and blame your upbringing
for so long where if you want to make a
dramatic change in your life you have
the power to do it and there's tons of
people who've done it and there's tons
of people who who started with way less
look good most successful famous
entrepreneurs people that you look up to
people who think now are living the the
big life look at where they started look
at where they came from chances are they
had way less in terms of money in terms
of Education in terms of resource and
some connections than what you already
have right now the difference is their
mindset the difference is that they took
responsibility for where they're at the
difference is they they said if I'm
gonna get to where I need to go nobody's
gonna hand it to me
I need to do this myself and so if you
look yourself in the mirror and you're
saying why am I not successful and
you're coming back with excuses then
that's what you need to change
I recognize that as soon as you
understand that this is on you to change
your life it's on you to build your
business and nobody's coming to save you
and that you can do it once you accept
responsibility things start to change
it's take no less than 100%
responsibility for your life you know
one of the greatest myths that's
pervasive in our culture today is that
you're entitled to a great life and then
somehow somewhere someone is responsible
for filling our lives with continual
happiness and exciting career options a
nurturing family and blissful personal
relationships simply because we exist
but the real truth is that there's only
one person responsible for the quality
of your life and that person is you you
see everything about you is a result of
your doing or not doing your income your
debt your relationships your health your
fitness level your attitudes and
behaviors everything
that person you see when you look in the
mirror is the chief architect in your
life you know I think everybody knows
this in their heart of hearts but the
mind can play games tricking us into
thinking that there are external factors
that are the source of our failures our
disappointments and our unhappiness but
the truth of the matter is that external
factors don't determine how you live you
and only you are in complete control of
the quality of your life experience
successful people take full
responsibility for the thoughts they
think the images they visualize and the
actions they take they don't waste their
time and energy on blaming and
complaining they evaluate their
experiences and decide if they need to
change them or not they face the
uncomfortable and they take risks in
order to create the life that they want
to live there is no such thing as
complete control nothing
no one has complete control in any
situation people that leading
organizations in some ways have less
because not only do they have to control
what they do they have to help persuade
everyone else what they do but you know
if you are able to take responsibility
I'm not late because there was traffic
I'm late because I didn't leave early
enough to account for the fact that
there was traffic the project didn't get
finished not because my friend my
partner didn't do it my colleague didn't
do his part the thought the project
didn't get finished because I didn't set
up a team where my colleague wanted to
do his part when you take responsibility
and you take full responsibility that is
the most empowering thing and you can do
it at any stage you have to do it if
you're raising money as an entrepreneur
you have to do it if you are if you're
trying to persuade people to work with
you you have to do it at all stages
trying to think of how to stop the loop
of my sacrifices have been rejected and
and the way that you stop that loop is
instead of saying this my sacrifices
were rejected so my hard work my effort
my everything that I'm doing to try and
move forward it's not working
and
and if you want to go towards hell you
keep saying well it's it's not working
but it's but it's because of everyone
else it's they're rejecting me they're
not accepting what I've done whereas if
you say to yourself oh it didn't work
okay it's my fault what can I do better
and that's how you start moving in the
other direction
what were you working at McDonald's and
that was an acting training ground for
you and one else is what you make your
purchases I mean I so I went to UCLA I
was a literature major meant that my dad
want to be me to be a math major I
wanted to go to art school to compromise
that I say literature once I got to UCLA
I would you know I realized you know
half the towns in the movie business and
suddenly I saw that they were practical
steps I could take to get into the
movies and I didn't seem to be doing
that you know in my Milton class you
know it just seemed like the long road
to I didn't even know where and so I
eventually dropped out of UCLA after a
year went to acting school in the valley
and and my parents said they wouldn't
support me if I wasn't going to
university and so I had to get a job and
I couldn't you know all the other actors
had better off you know they were they
got all the great waiting jobs and
somebody said you too good to work at
McDonald's I said no and you know it was
a you know cuz I I wanted to be an actor
I never felt like that was the only way
I would I would be able to do it it was
not it was a really important lesson
actually that you know going and working
and being responsible for myself really
showed me how much I wanted to act like
it wasn't the soft way you know I had to
really work for it I walked around GE
preaching constantly don't you ever
think you're a victim if you ever feel
like a victim
get out cuz if enough of you get out
we'll find out who's making you feel
like a victim it's your job to take
responsibility go find another game
there's plenty of games here
unemployment slow here
go find something else go on your own do
something
but Jesus don't spend most your waking
hours feeling like a victim
now I've got a very special take
responsibilty bonus clip with brian
tracy and i think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that i want to know
what do you need to take more
responsibility of in your life in your
business what's a single area that you
have not owned up to enough leave it
down the comments below I really want to
hear from you I'm really looking forward
to hearing what you have to say and I
hope that by writing it down now you're
gonna own it you've made it public
you've shared it now you're going to own
it so put in the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
if you have made a mistake or something
has happened in the past that's
unfortunate you can cancel it out by
simply saying the magic words I am
responsible I am responsible I am
responsible if someone has hurt you or
you've had a difficult experience in
your childhood you can say well I didn't
do anything yes but you're responsible
for how you respond today a nobel
prize-winning study of the evolution of
civilizations came up with the term
responsibility is your ability to
respond effectively with the ups and
downs and negative events of life is the
key measure of your ability to be
successful and happy in the future and
the what you do is you say whenever you
feel negative or unhappy about anything
you say wait a minute I'm responsible
I'm responsible for my life I'm
responsible for what happens I can't
change the past so I'm not going to
spend a second worrying about the past
I'm going to become so busy working on
my future and my goals that I don't have
time to think about the past raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion and
not one drop of most self-worth depends
on your acceptance of me I don't ever
give up
I'd have to be
that are completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten roses success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details